foreign
that I've come up with I call it
consumerism
but it's the layer cake of consumerism
so I want to talk to you guys about the
layer cake of consumerism because when
we talk about consumerism what are we
usually talking about the first layer of
consumerism material possessions I call
that traditional consumerism but if
we're building a cake on top of that we
often get past the traditional
consumerism and then we just turn into
consumers consumerists of other types of
consumerism there's pleasure consumerism
gluttony dopamine spikes from food and
sex and drugs and entertainment nothing
wrong with those things but when it
becomes that Pursuit that will complete
us it becomes a problem the next layer
is Success consumerism okay the things
aren't working for me you know what the
pleasures aren't working for me anymore
I need more more what do I need more of
I need more success is that why you
bought that Bentley
just kidding Josh does not known of
Bentley and so the career
consumerism or it can be achievement
consumerism Pride consumerism all goes
under success consumerism right so what
we do is we pursue the things
that didn't make me happy oh you know it
will make me happy more pleasure more
pleasurable Pursuits more sex more drugs
more alcohol more entertainment more
food it's gluttony and it for a while it
gives us the pleasure we mistake that
pleasure for a long lasting Bliss or
Tranquility or peace but of course it
disrupts our piece then we move to
success consumerism if I have the right
achievements the right career the right
job title the right accomplishments I
win the correct Awards and I'll be
complete that doesn't work either so we
move up to the next rung of the layer
cake the next layer on the layer cake
it's experience consumerism and that's
what we've been talking about today on
the private podcast intentional travel
and all the different ways to travel
intentionally
that allows us to experience a place
without consuming the place because it's
easy to okay I've shed the success
consumerism I've shed the pleasure of
consumerism I've shed the material
possessions traditional consumerism and
now I'm just going to experience the
wonderlust of travel I'm going to
consume every place I go to and that
doesn't make us complete either if we
show up incomplete no place that we
travel to will ever complete us and I
think the top layer of this layer cake
of consumerism is
what I would call spiritual consumerism
some people might call it religious
consumerism or God consumerism we're
trying to make ourselves complete by
testing out all of these different
religions there's nothing wrong with the
knowledge or the wisdom from these
ancient traditions in fact that wisdom
can be really useful in our lives but
when we think I'm going to complete
Myself by finding just the right
religion I'm going to shun this one that
I was a part of so I can go join this
one
it doesn't complete us either in fact it
often leaves us feeling empty just like
all of these other layers in the layer
cake of consumerism so what is the
antidote to this
it's letting go of the pursuit of
completeness
like just thinking about being raised as
Jehovah's Witness they would tell you
it's impossible to be complete without
you know their guidance and their their
beliefs and their values and
um man yeah there's something in me
that's like I want to fight what you
just said but it's true it's like we
unfortunately we do look to
um yeah these spiritual aspects to
complete us but if we show up completed
man how much more powerful is that I saw
this meme the other day it was like
um it was a picture
uh it was commentary on a meme and uh
someone retweeted it and the meme said
uh uh uh
Satan
teaches you to believe in yourself
instead of God
and the commentary was man I know this
is against Satan but it actually makes
him sound kind of cool
yeah so he's a motivational speaker
right yeah yeah anyway what do you have
to say TK about this consumerist layer
cake the layer cake of consumerism yeah
I I think at the heart of what you're
saying here is that consumerism isn't
about what you consume it's about how
you go about it and anything can be the
object of addiction if your relationship
to it is unhealthy religion and
spirituality is no exception one of the
things I've always believed is that
selling your soul isn't just limited to
things like giving up your artistic
dreams for the sake of money you can
sell your soul for Noble things as well
you can sell your soul by going the
other way around you can sell your soul
by leaving behind a career in accounting
you can sell your soul through
practicing a religion not because of the
thing itself but because of the mindset
behind it anything that you do 2 can be
done in a way that's unhealthy and so
there's something very dangerous about
thinking hey because I am in a religious
environment or because I am doing
something that is outwardly dignified I
don't have to think critically anymore I
don't have to live mindfully anymore I
can turn my brain off you know I can
check my critical thinking in at the
door and I can just Outsource everything
to this person or that institution or
this practice no you've always got to
bring your heart and your mind with you
in whatever you do or else you'll become
a slave to something you know outside of
yourself that's not healthy
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100 advertisement free